This is 99% In December of 2020, 99% Invisible released a special mini-series called, according to NEED. It was a riveting and revelatory exploration of the complex systems in place to help homeless people find housing in the Bay Area. Former 99PI senior producer Katie Mangle spent two years reporting the story for us, and a couple weeks ago, we learned that the series received a DuPont Columbia award honoring the best in journalism.
This is 99% 2020年12月，《99% Invisible》发布了一个名为《根据需求》（According to Need）的特别迷你剧集。它对湾区帮助无家可归者寻找住房的复杂体系进行了引人入胜且发人深省的探索。前 99PI 高级制作人凯蒂·曼格（Katie Mangle）为我们花了两年时间报道这个故事，几周前，我们得知该系列获得了杜邦-哥伦比亚奖（DuPont Columbia award），该奖项旨在表彰杰出的新闻报道。
In celebration, we are replaying the first couple stories from according to need, plus I'll catch up with Katie Mangle, who now works at a new podcast venture called, my name right here. Serial? Serial. Never heard of it.
为了庆祝这一点，我们正在重播《根据需求》的前几个故事，另外我将采访凯蒂·曼格，她现在在一个名为……我名字就在这的新播客风险企业工作。《连线》（Serial）？《连线》。没听说过。
First, I want to start with congratulations, Katie, on winning the DuPont Columbia award. Thank you. It's so exciting. It's amazing. What does it look like? It looks like a big heavy baton that you could use to, like, bludgeon a burglar.
首先，我想向凯蒂表达祝贺，祝贺你赢得杜邦-哥伦比亚奖。谢谢。这太令人兴奋了。太棒了。它长什么样？它看起来像一个又大又重的指挥棒，你可以用它来，比如，殴打一个强盗。
It's silver. it's really heavy. It's a solid thing to hold. So in celebration of according to need, winning the Deuteronque Columbia Award, we're gonna represent the prologue in the first episode, and then we should chat a little bit afterwards to see if there's any updates on the rest of the series.
它是银色的，真的很重。拿在手里很扎实。因此，为了庆祝《根据需求》赢得杜邦-哥伦比亚奖，我们将重播序幕和第一集，之后我们应该聊一聊，看看其余剧集是否有任何更新。
Great, yeah. I live in the north part of Oakland near the border of Berkeley in Emoryville. Like other gentrifying places, this one was recently given a cutesy name by real estate agents hoping to attract new people to the area. No B for North Oakland, Berkeley, Emoryville. I'm not sure the name is stuck, but the new people certainly have. They've moved into the 1920s bungalows and craftsmen's, painting and landscaping, and refurbishing the neighborhood.
太好了，是的。我住在奥克兰北部，靠近伯克利和埃默里维尔的边境。和其他正在士绅化的地区一样，这个地方最近被房地产经纪人起了一个可爱的小名字，希望能吸引新人来到这个地区。北奥克兰、伯克利、埃默里维尔的 NoB。我不确定这个名字是否流传开来，但新人们绝对留下来了。他们搬进了20世纪20年代的平房和工匠风格住宅，粉刷、做园林绿化，并翻新了这个社区。
My girlfriend and I moved to this neighborhood last year, and we were thrilled to find our apartment, because it was two bedrooms with a nice big kitchen and a washer and dryer in the unit my first ever. All this and the rent was still under $3,000 a month, which for the area was actually extremely reasonable. I know, insane. But true. As we settled into the new place and started meeting neighbors, it didn't take long
我和女友去年搬到了这个社区，我们很高兴能找到我们的公寓，因为它是两居室，带有一个漂亮的大厨房，而且屋里有洗衣机和烘干机——这是我的生平头一次。这一切的租金居然还在每月3,000美元以下，对于这个地区来说，这实际上非常合理。我知道，这太疯狂了。但这是真的。当我们安顿在新住所并开始结识邻居时，没过多久
before we realized that some of them were homeless. There was a guy sleeping in an old Lexus right in front of our house and another guy who seemed to be living in the cabin of a boat parked on the side of the road just across the street from us. I was already working on this series about homelessness. So of course I went to go say hi to the boat guy. Knock knock. Hey. Hey, how's it going? I'm your neighbor. Oh, how you doing? Good, how are you? I just took a bath soon. Right now I'm trying to get to work. I'm squinting up at my boat dwelling neighbor, his name is Michael. The vessel he lives on is a 15-foot speedboat with little sleeping cabin, and is named
我们就意识到他们中的一些人无家可归。有一个家伙睡在我们房子正前方的一辆旧雷克萨斯里，还有一个家伙似乎住在我们街对面路边停着的一艘船的船舱里。我当时已经在制作这个关于无家可归者的系列节目了。所以我当然去跟那个船老大打招呼了。敲敲门。嘿。嘿，最近怎么样？我是你的邻居。哦，你好吗？很好，你呢？我刚洗了个澡。现在我正赶去上班。我眯起眼睛看着我的船民邻居，他叫迈克尔。他住的船是一艘15英尺长的快艇，带有一个小小的休息舱，名字叫
Graba Dupa, or something like that. Graba Dupa. Graba Dupa, so yeah. Quick but important interjection here, I found out later that Graba Dupa means fat ass in Polish. Did you, who named it that? Yeah, my nephew. He just wanted a name on the water. They'd be on the CB. Grubba dupa coming through. Grubba dupa coming through.
Graba Dupa，或者类似的名字。Graba Dupa。Graba Dupa，所以是的。这里有个简短但重要的插曲，我后来发现 Graba Dupa 在波兰语中是“混蛋”的意思。真的吗，谁给它取的名字？是的，我侄子。他只是想在水面上起个名字。他们会在 CB 电台上喊。Grubba dupa 通过了。Grubba dupa 通过了。
Michael is wearing jeans and an orange fluorescent vest and holding a hard hat. I find out later he's an electrician on a construction crew for a new high rise in San Francisco. Hi, so I live right over there and I'm also a journalist and I've been doing a bunch of reporting on people who are living like RVs and cars and I haven't talked to anyone that's living in a boat. It's very fascinating. What I most want to know about Michael is where he's from, like where he lived before he was homeless. There's this persistent myth about homelessness, maybe especially persistent in California, that the homeless people here aren't really from here. Some people suggest that maybe folks came here from other areas
迈克尔穿着牛仔裤、一件荧光橙色背心，手里拿着一顶安全帽。我后来发现他是旧金山一处新高层建筑施工队的电工。嗨，我住在就在那边的那个地方，我也是一名记者，我一直在做大量关于住在房车和汽车里的人的报道，但我没有和住在船上的人聊过。这太迷人了。我最想了解迈克尔的是他是哪里人，比如他在无家可归之前住在哪里。关于无家可归有一个根深蒂固的神话，在加州可能尤其根深蒂固，即这里的无家可归者其实不是本地人。有些人暗示，也许人们从其他地方来到这里
to take advantage of better social services or better weather. But the data doesn't support this. The last big survey done in Oakland found 78% of homeless respondents in the city of Oakland reported living in this county, Alameda County, at the time they became homeless. And most of the rest of the respondents just came from some other county in California. I suspect Michael is from Oakland,
是为了利用更好的社会福利或更好的天气。但数据并不支持这一点。奥克兰最近做的一次大型调查发现，该市78%的无家可归受访者表示，在他们无家可归时，他们居住在这个县，即阿拉米达县。其余的大多数受访者只是来自加利福尼亚州的另一个县。我怀疑迈克尔是奥克兰人，
maybe even from this neighborhood. My mother knew you were some peace, mom. We used to stay right there. Wait, where? You're in that house right there? I'm in the like beige, tall one. Yeah, that tall one? Yeah.
甚至可能就来自这个社区。我妈妈认识你，妈妈。我们过去常住在那里。等等，在哪里？你就住在那个房子里吗？我住在米色、高高的那个。对，那个高高的？对。
We used to stay there. You used to stay where I live? Yes. Me and my mother and my younger brother. In case you didn't catch that with the traffic noise, Michael is not only from this neighborhood, he used to live in my house. He tells me later he hasn't lived in that house for many years since the 1990s, and then he moved
我们以前就住在那。你以前住在我住的地方？是的。我和我妈妈还有我弟弟。如果你因为交通噪音没有听清的话，迈克尔不仅是这个社区的人，他以前就住在我的房子里。他后来告诉我，他已经很多年没住在那个房子里了，从20世纪90年代开始就没有了，然后他搬到了
right next door, lived there for a bunch of years, and then he left the neighborhood for a while, struggled with addiction, got clean, and finally he ended up back here on the Blocky Most Consider's home, and where he still has friends from the old days. A lot of us, me and Toe Free, wanted to sleep in the lexas. Yeah. His dad, he used to stay in one, two, three, four, about five houses down, they had a trucking company called Toe Free Trucking. Nice trucks. Oh my God. Of course, it makes perfect sense that most of Oakland's homeless population would be
隔壁，在那里住了好几年，然后他离开这个社区一段时间，与毒瘾作斗争，戒了毒，最后他终于回到了这个大多数人认为是家的地方，在这里他仍然有老朋友。我们很多人，我和 Toe Free，想睡在雷克萨斯里。对。他爸爸，他以前住在大概往下五栋房子的其中一栋，他们有一家卡车运输公司叫 Toe Free Trucking。好车。哦，天哪。当然，奥克兰绝大多数无家可归的人口都来自奥克兰，这完全合情合理。
from Oakland. If you have even the most cursory awareness of what's happened to the housing market here in the last decade, let's take the building I live in, where Michael used to live, as an example. It's a 2,200 square foot duplex in North Oakland. In 2009 the assessment records showed it was worth $105,000. Last year it was assessed at a million dollars and would probably sell for quite a bit more than that. In the last five years especially thousands of people like me have moved to the Bay Area for jobs and the cost of rent in places like Oakland and Berkeley
如果你对过去十年这里住房市场发生的事情哪怕只有最粗略的了解，让我们以我住的这栋房子为例，迈克尔以前就住在这里。这是北奥克兰的一栋2200平方英尺的双户住宅。2009年，评估记录显示它价值10.5万美元。去年它的估价是一百万美元，实际售价可能会高得多。特别是过去五年里，成千上万像我这样的人为了工作搬到了湾区，奥克兰和伯克利等地的房租成本
has skyrocketed. Low income African-American residents in the area have been the hardest hit by all of this. As new people have arrived, thousands of black people have moved away, and thousands have become homeless. My own neighborhood reflects this. My goal and I reflect this. My own neighborhood reflects this. Michael and I reflect this. But far beyond my block, you can see the effects of these economic and demographic shifts. Almost as if a tidal wave of wealth
已经飙升。该地区低收入的非裔美国居民受到的打击最重。随着新人的到来，成千上万的黑人搬走了，成千上万的人无家可归。我自己的社区反映了这一点。我的目标和我反映了这一点。我自己的社区反映了这一点。迈克尔和我反映了这一点。但在我的街区之外，你可以看到这些经济和人口结构转变的影响。几乎就像是一场财富的 tidal wave（潮汐）
has washed the poor people of the Bay Area out of their houses and into the streets. [♪ music playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background, playing in the background I like a lot of people. I probably looked past all of this for a while. But eventually, just the sheer scale of it in my city became so startling that I started wanting to understand it and report on it. I didn't know what the story I wanted to tell was for a while, and it took me a bit to figure it out. Because there's this whole huge world you have to try to understand first. And to start this series, I want to take you on a little tour of this world, so that you can get a sense of it. The most visible way that homeless people live in the Bay Area is the tent encampment.
把湾区的穷人从他们的房子里冲刷出去，赶到了街上。[♪ 背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中] 我和很多人一样。我可能有一段时间对所有这些视而不见。但最终，它在我所在城市的绝对规模变得如此惊人，以至于我开始想要了解它并对其进行报道。有一段时间我不知道我想讲的故事是什么，我花了一点时间才弄清楚。因为这里有一个巨大的世界，你必须先试着去理解它。为了开始这个系列，我想带你参观一下这个世界，让你对它有一个概念。湾区无家可归者最显眼的生活方式就是帐篷营地。
Most of these encampments are easily seen from the road. In fact, they're practically in the road. Tents and tarps and belongings spilling off of sidewalks and industries. But the encampment where Elizabeth Easton lives, in a tiny little house made out of plywood and two by fours. It was sort of hidden away down a dirt path next to some railroad tracks. Elizabeth told me she's always liked the idea of living in a tiny house. That's all I used to watch. Tiny house. On TV, yes, more than one. Tiny house living, tiny house nation.
这些营地大部分从公路上都能轻易看到。事实上，它们几乎就在公路边上。帐篷、防水布和随身物品从人行道和工业区溢出。但伊丽莎白·伊斯顿（Elizabeth Easton）居住的营地，在一个由胶合板和两乘四木方块搭建的小房子里。它被隐藏在铁路旁的一条土路尽头。伊丽莎白告诉我，她一直很喜欢住在小房子里的想法。我以前看的就是这个。Tiny house（小房子）。在电视上，是的，不止一个。《微型房屋生活》（Tiny House Living）、《微型房屋国家》（Tiny House Nation）。
She'd like to have a tiny house on some land that she's actually allowed to live on, but that's not what she has right now. Do you gonna show me? Elizabeth's house is dark and windowless. There's a futon that takes up most of the space and then piles of tools and clothes. And then what's in that room? That's why I have my little toilet over there. Elizabeth's bathroom is maybe two and a half square feet with a dirt floor and one
她希望在某块她实际上被允许居住的土地上拥有一栋小房子，但那不是她现在拥有的。你要带我去看吗？伊丽莎白的小房子黑暗而没有窗户。里面有一个折叠沙发，占据了大部分空间，然后是一堆堆的工具和衣服。然后那个房间里是什么？那就是我放我的小马桶的地方。伊丽莎白的浴室大概有两点五平方英尺，泥土地面，还有一个
of those medical looking toilet chairs with a bucket underneath. Every few days she empties the bucket and burns the waste. She also has a small front yard with a fence made out of pallets where her two dogs can lounge in the sun. It's a far cry from the places you see on tiny house nation, but it's still home. I know one thing, I'm not homeless. I put it that way. It can say what they want to say, but I'm not homeless. I'll put it that way. You know what I mean? It can say what they want to say, but I'm not homeless. I have a home. Elizabeth preferred to think of herself, not as homeless, but as home-steading. Home-steading is what she felt like she had done.
那种看起来像医疗用的马桶椅，下面放着一个桶。每隔几天她就倒掉桶里的东西并烧掉排泄物。她还有一个小前院，用托盘做成的栅栏，她的两只狗可以在那里晒太阳。这和你在《微型房屋国家》里看到的那些地方相去甚远，但它仍然是家。我知道有一件事，我不是无家可归。我这么说吧。他们想说什么就说什么，但我不是无家可归。我这么说吧。你知道我的意思吗？他们想说什么就说什么，但我不是无家可归。我有一个家。伊丽莎白更愿意认为自己不是无家可归，而是 homesteading（宅基地开拓）。宅基地开拓是她觉得她自己做过的事。
Found a little piece of land and claimed it as her own, built her own tiny house. But in her most powerless moments, she would talk about herself as homeless. Homesteading was a good day. Homest was the day the police came and told her she couldn't be where she was anymore. Which had happened before and would happen again. Of course not everyone lives in an encampment.
找到了一小片土地，并宣布它是她自己的，建了她自己的小房子。但在她最无力的时刻，她会谈到自己是无家可归。宅基地开拓是美好的一天。无家可归的日子是警察来告诉她，她不能再呆在原来的地方的那一天。这以前发生过，以后还会发生。当然，并不是每个人都住在营地里。
There are lots of people living in more hidden ways. A few miles from Elizabeth in what people sometimes call deep east Oakland. I'm at Reggie. See what I'm calling that? Come on. That's a lot. He sometimes sleeps in a broken-down minivan that's parked behind a house with a pit bull on a chain.
有很多人以更隐蔽的方式生活。离伊丽莎白几英里远的地方，在人们有时称之为东奥克兰深处的地方。我遇到了雷吉（Reggie）。看我怎么叫这个的？来吧。那很多。他有时睡在一辆破旧的微型面包车里，车停在一栋房子后面，旁边拴着一只比特犬。
But he can only sleep in the van when he can scrounge up ten bucks. That's how much he has to pay to the owner of the van per night. He gets the money by panhandling. Could you just say where we are for the recording? Oh, we got the McDonald's. Everyone who lives in Oakland has been asked for money at some point by a panhandler. And there's long been an idea that giving cash to people on the street is the wrong way to support them.
但他只有在能凑够十块钱时才能睡在面包车里。那是他每晚必须支付给面包车主人的钱。他的钱是通过乞讨得来的。你能为录音说一下我们现在在哪里吗？哦，我们在麦当劳。所有住在奥克兰的人都曾在某个时候被乞讨者要过钱。长期以来有一种观点认为，给街头的人现金是支持他们的错误方式。
But I will say after my two years in the field, I basically think that's garbage. Some people buy drugs, sure. But even the ones who do are also buying food or water or like Reggie renting themselves a place to sleep at night. Like anyone else they have a budget. Reggie has strong feelings about the do's and don'ts of asking people for money which he was kind enough to guide me through. You know, you see some people don't do it right? Like, come on, let me show you something. It's certain, certain, certain place you should stand. His first piece of advice, don't stand between the window where the people pay and the window
但我得说，经过我在实地两年的经历，我基本上认为那是垃圾。有些人买毒品，当然。但即使是那些买毒品的人，他们也买食物或水，或者像雷吉一样给自己租个地方晚上睡觉。和其他人一样，他们也有预算。雷吉对向人们要钱的“该做”和“不该做”有着强烈的看法，他很友好地带我了解了这些。你知道，你看有些人做得不对，对吧？来吧，我给你看样东西。有些，有些，有些地方你应该站着。他的第一个建议，不要站在人们付钱的窗户和他们取食物的
where they get their food. This is bad etiquette. This is a hell of ghetto. This is ghetto. Oh, oh. Oh, that's it. All right. Okay.
窗户之间。这是不礼貌的。这是地狱般的贫民窟。这是贫民窟。哦，哦。哦，就是这样。好吧。好的。
From this spot, you can see what changed people get before they even have a chance to put it back in their wallet. That ain't cool, you know, that is not cool. I think that's... That's like too aggressive, that's a great thing. Also, don't bother people with kids, at least not in this part of Oakland, where everybody, even people with houses are struggling. You're taking away from the kids, well, you know, I don't like to do that, you know. And finally, don't be too hurt when people say no. That's when Reggie had to learn over time. But you know, I'm just glad it don't hurt like I used to.
从这个位置，你可以看到人们甚至在有机会把它放回钱包之前就有了零钱。那可不酷，你知道，那可不酷。我认为那是……这就像太具有攻击性了，这是一件大事。另外，不要打扰带孩子的 人，至少在这个奥克兰的这一部分不要，这里每个人，甚至有房子的人都在苦苦挣扎。你夺走了孩子们的福利，嗯，你知道，我不想那样做，你知道。最后，当人们说不时，不要太受伤。那是雷吉随着时间推移必须学会的。但你知道，我只是很高兴它不像以前那样痛了。
It's hard not to get hurt when the stakes are this high. If Reggie can't panhandle the ten bucks for the minivan, It's hard not to get hurt when the stakes are this high. If Redgie can't panhandle the ten bucks for the minivan, he won't have anywhere to sleep tonight, and he'll end up just wandering the streets. Redgie told me he wanted to find his stable place to live with his high school-aged daughter, who is also homeless and stays with a friend.
当赌注这么高时，很难不受伤。如果雷吉不能为面包车乞讨到十块钱，当赌注这么高时，很难不受伤。如果雷吉不能为面包车乞讨到十块钱，他今晚就没有地方睡觉了，他最终只能在街上游荡。雷吉告诉我，他想和他上高中的女儿找一个稳定的地方住，他的女儿也无家可归，和一个朋友住在一起。
But most of the time, he's so busy trying to survive that he just can't try to path out of this life. It's hard to get out of the time he's so busy trying to survive that he just can't try to path out of this life. It's hard to get out of your home when you're homeless. You don't know what your life's gonna be the next two hours. You know, it just like swallows you up. And do you feel like there's a way for you to break above that cycle? I can even answer that right now. Not all I know, I'm just, as my baby said,
但大多数时候，他太忙于生存，以至于他根本无法尝试找出一条摆脱这种生活的道路。当你无家可归时，很难摆脱你的一天他太忙于生存，以至于他根本无法尝试找出一条摆脱这种生活的道路。当你无家可归时，很难摆脱你的生活。你不知道接下来的两个小时你的生活会变成什么样。你知道，它就像把你吞噬了一样。你觉得有办法打破这个循环吗？我现在甚至无法回答这个问题。不，我所知道的，我只是，就像我的宝贝说的，
day by day dead. Day by day is how everyone I met outside lived. It's hard to make plans for the future and carry through with them while homeless. There's always some new crisis to deal with. Maybe your phone gets stolen or you lose your ID or you have to pick up all your things and move as fast as you can because someone doesn't want you where you are.
一天过一天。一天过一天就是我在外面遇到的所有人的生活方式。无家可归时，很难为未来做计划并贯彻执行。总是有一些新的危机需要处理。也许你的手机被偷了，或者你弄丢了身份证，或者你必须收拾好所有的东西，以最快的速度搬家，因为有人不希望你呆在他们的地方。
So if you turn your car all the way off, it just starts honking. Yeah, look. Talia Garcia and her husband and six kids often end up sleeping in the car when they can't find a friend or relative to crash with. Today, she's parked in front of her kids elementary school and her beat up old Ford Explorer. And her crisis right now is that when she turns her car off, it lets out an unending honk, which is mortifying. There's always something happening to me.
所以如果你把车完全熄火，它就会开始按喇叭。是的，看。塔莉娅·加西亚（Talia Garcia）和她的丈夫以及六个孩子在找不到朋友或亲戚家借宿时，经常最后睡在车里。今天，她把她破旧的老福特探险者停在她孩子的小学前面。她眼下的危机是，当她把车熄火时，它会发出没完没了的喇叭声，这太丢脸了。总是有事情发生在我身上。
Yeah. Yeah. I'm just like, OK. I don't even know what to think anymore. Talia had just had a little bit of good news, though. She found a woman who was willing to run a room to her and her husband and their kids. It was just one room for all eight of them,
是的。是的。我只是觉得，好吧。我甚至不知道该想什么了。不过，塔莉娅刚刚听到了一点好消息。她找到了一位愿意把一个房间租给她、她的丈夫和他们的孩子们的妇女。他们八个人挤在一个房间里，
and it was only for a few months. Still, it was something. She wasn't sure what she would do after the three months was over, but she couldn't think too much about it at the moment. Because now, there was a new crisis. Her car battery was dead. Like Michael and Elizabeth and Reggie and everyone I got to know over the last two years, Talia wanted permanent stable housing. She just couldn't figure out how to get it. For a lot of homeless people, the high cost of rent, coupled with the other barriers, like
而且只租几个月。尽管如此，这总算是个东西。她不确定三个月结束后她会怎么做，但她目前无法想太多。因为现在，有了一个新的危机。她的汽车电瓶没电了。就像迈克尔、伊丽莎白、雷吉以及我在过去两年里认识的每个人一样，塔莉娅想要永久稳定的住房。她只是不知道该如何得到它。对许多无家可归的人来说，高昂的租金，加上其他障碍，如
deposit and good credit, rule out being able to get housing on their own without some kind of subsidy. There's Section 8, now officially called Housing Choice, which is a voucher program for low-income folks, but the wait lists are all currently closed in the Bay Area. Besides Section 8, there's the occasional low-income housing development that opens up. But the last one I heard about in Oakland had 28 units, and they got 4,000 applications. And so what's left in terms of help? Basically, what's left is the homeless service system.
押金和良好的信用，排除了在没有某种补贴的情况下靠自己获得住房的可能性。有第8条款（Section 8），现在官方称为住房选择（Housing Choice），这是一个针对低收入人群的凭证项目，但在湾区，等待名单目前全都关闭了。除了第8条款，偶尔会有开放的低收入住房开发项目。但我听说奥克兰的最后一个项目有28个单位，却收到了4,000份申请。那么在帮助方面还剩下什么呢？基本上，剩下的就是无家可归者服务体系。
It might surprise some of you to know that we even have a system in place to help homeless people get inside. But we do. And after exploring a lot of different corners of the world of homelessness and talking to hundreds of people, this system is what I decided this series should be about. Because this is it. Like this is the system we have right now to solve homelessness Which is a huge issue in this country. We already have hundreds of thousands of people dealing with homelessness nationwide And we may soon see a dramatic increase due to COVID related job losses and evictions And so how this system works is a question with huge stakes. And yet it's
你们中的一些人可能会惊讶地发现，我们甚至有一个系统来帮助无家可归的人进入室内。但我们确实有。在探索了无家可归世界的许多不同角落并与数百人交谈之后，这个系统就是我决定这个系列应该关注的内容。因为就是这样。就像这是我们目前解决无家可归问题的系统，这是一个在这个国家巨大的问题。我们全国已经有数十万人面临无家可归的问题，由于与新冠疫情相关的工作岗位流失和驱逐，我们可能很快会看到急剧增加。因此，这个系统是如何运作的，是一个事关重大的问题。然而，它却是我老实说不得不付出最多努力去理解的这个世界的一部分。它令人困惑且不透明。有人可能会说卡夫卡式的，他们说得一点也没错。我遇到的每个人都与这个系统互动过。有些人像雷吉一样，已经对它放弃了希望。这个设计就是为了留住一个妈的男人。这不是为了让任何人出头而设计的。这些程序不是为了真正出头而设计的。其他人，比如塔莉娅，还在等着从它那里得到一些东西。成为他们的优先对象需要什么？我不明白。
the part of this world that I honestly had to work the hardest to understand. It's confusing and opaque. Some might say Kafka-esque and they wouldn't be wrong. Everyone I met had interacted with this system. Some like Reggie had given up on it. This is designed to keep a mo-damn man. This is not designed for nobody to come up. These programs are not designed to really come up. Other people like Talia were still waiting to get something from it. What does it take to be priority for them? I don't understand it.
塔莉娅并不孤单。很多人不明白在这个系统中成为优先对象需要什么。但我终于可以说我懂了。这是一个根据需求优先分配资源的系统。但是你如何决定一个人是否比另一个人更需要住房？当有这么多人需要它时，谁能真正得到帮助？这里是《根据需求》第一章，Tulecia。看到正前方的山雀了吗？是的。
Talia isn't alone. A lot of people don't understand what it takes to be a priority in this system. But I can finally say that I do. It's a system that prioritizes resources according to need. But how do you decide whether one person needs housing more than another? And who actually gets help when there are so many people who need it? Here is according to need, chapter 1, Tulecia. See the tits straight ahead? Yeah.
到处都是。是的。是的，我们直走。那辆车就在那。无家可归。我对蒂莉·雪莉（Tilly Shelley）的大多数采访都是在车里进行的。仔细想想，我对无家可归者的绝大多数采访都是在车里进行的。
It's everywhere. Yeah. Yeah, we go go straight. That car right there. Homeless. Most of my interviews with Tilly Shelley took place in a car. Come to think of it, most of my interviews with homeless people in general took place in cars.
汽车作为工作室很好。它们很安静，没有回声。作为家，它们的表现就不那么好了。但奥克兰有非常多的人正以这种方式使用它们。你们都好吗？嗯-嗯。他们就在那。蒂莉·沙莉（Tilly Shally）指出了东奥克兰仅仅几个街区内所有睡在车里的人。
Cars are good as studios. They're quiet, they don't have an echo. They are less good as homes. But many, many people in Oakland are using them that way. Do you all right? Mm-hmm. They're fair right there. Tilly Shally is pointing out all the people sleeping in cars on just a few blocks in East Oakland.
有时你真的看不出一辆车里是否住着人。但通常有迹象。遮住窗户的毯子，绑在车顶上的手提箱。那些车就在那。这辆车就在这。我认识这些人。我认识这些车。这辆车在这，我认识这些人，我认识这些人，我认识那些人。全都是无家可归的。
Sometimes you really can't tell when a car has a person living in it. But often there are signs. Blinkets covering windows, suitcases, strap, to roofs. Them cars right there. This car right here. I know these people right here. I know these cars right there. This car right here, I know these people right here, I know these people right here, I know them people right there. All homeless.
全都在我的车里无家可归。奥克兰在2019年记录了727人睡在车里。尽管这被普遍认为是一个保守的数字，特别是由于交通工具中的人们往往不像帐篷里的人那样显眼。蒂莉斯（Tilece）很擅长发现这些车，因为她熟悉这个社区，但还有另一个原因。
All homeless in my cars. Oakland recorded 727 people sleeping in cars in 2019. Although that's widely considered to be an undercount, especially because folks in vehicles tend to be less visible than say people in tents. Tilece is good at spotting these cars because she knows this neighborhood, but there's another reason too.
有时她和她11岁的儿子乔丹（Jordan）也睡在车里。所以你看是怎么回事？是的，我把我的座位往后放了一点。我只是难过地在这里录一会儿音。我们有所有的掩护。然后我把我的脚裹双层。这样我的脚就不会冷，因为半夜我的脚真的很冷。
Sometimes she and her 11 year old son, Jordan, also sleep in the car. So you see what's up? Yeah, I put my seat back somewhere. I was just sad to record it right here for a minute. We got all the cover. Then I wrapped my feet double. So my feet won't be cold because in the middle of the night my feet be real cold.
蒂莉丝坐在驾驶座上，她的儿子乔丹坐在副驾驶座上。她有着圆圆的脸庞和灿烂的微笑，门牙之间有一个小缝隙。她戴着一顶无檐小帽来保暖，并遮住她没有钱去做她喜欢的接发款式的短发。妈妈。对。你知道该怎么做吗？你觉得爸爸怎么样？我们需要一个房子。
T'Lisa is in the driver's seat and her son Jordan is in shotgun. She has a round face and a wide smile with a little gap between her front teeth. She wears a beanie to keep her head warm and to cover the short hair she hasn't had the money to get done the way she likes it with extensions. Mom. Yeah. You know what to do about? What do you think about daddy? We need a house.
我们需要一个房子。房子核心。我们需要一个房子核心。我们需要一个带轮子的房子。乔丹有着和他妈妈一样的圆脸，还有一个与之相配的圆肚子。他温和而害羞。他喜欢电子游戏和数学。蒂莉丝说她很庆幸他没有像他这个年龄的一些孩子那样试图表现得很成熟。顺便说一句，乔丹有残疾
We need a house. A house core. We need a house core. We need a house on wheels. Jordan has his mom's same round face plus a round belly to match. He's gentle and shy. He likes video games and math. And Tolisha says she's thankful he isn't trying to act all grown like some kids his age. By the way Jordan has a disability
这影响了他的言语和语言。我们用。好的。所以好样的。试一试，然后靠边停车去睡觉。好的。太棒了。是吗？好的。这就是你想要的。这就是你一直在想的。是的。好的。
that affects his speech and language. We use. Okay. So good try. Take a try and pull over and go to sleep. Okay. Super. Yeah? Okay. That's what you want. That's what you're just thinking about. Yeah. Okay.
一个好的。也是一个好的。尽管妈妈喜欢这个孩子。到2019年，蒂莉丝和乔丹已经无家可归五年了。有时他们和家人或朋友住在一起，有时他们最后落脚在车里。五年来，他们大多只是靠自己艰难地度过无家可归的日子。
A nice one. A nice one too. Even though mommy like the child. By 2019, Taelisha and Jordan had been homeless for five years. Sometimes they stayed with family or friends, and sometimes they ended up in the car. For five years, they'd mostly just struggled through homelessness on their own.
但随后情况发生了变化，他们终于开始尝试寻求一些帮助。这是《根据需求》第一章。这是《根据需求》第一章。我想把焦点集中在蒂莉丝开始寻求帮助的时候，以便我们能看看那是什么样的，并开始了解这个系统对谁管用，对谁不管用。但首先，我要回溯一下。我应该和你一起上车吗？你想上我的车？是的，好的。蒂莉丝在我们在车里进行的一系列采访中向我讲述了她的生活。
But then something changed, and they finally started trying to get some help. This is according to Need, chapter one. This is according to need, chapter one. I want to zero in on the time when Tullisha started asking for help, so that we can see what that looks like, and start to see who the system works for, and who it fails. But first, I want to go back. Should I get in with you, You want to get in my car? Yeah, okay. Tleisha told me about her life and a series of interviews we did in the car.
她从来没有过过轻松的日子。我小时候经历的那些事，教会了我生存技能。蒂莉丝的家族在她成长过程中很穷。她的父母都与毒瘾作斗争，她在16岁时就有了第一个孩子。我没有机会享受我的青少年时期，因为我是一个妈妈。蒂莉丝的生活中有那么多的障碍和不稳定，但不知何故，当她三十多岁时，她已经设法取得了普通教育文凭（GED），叉车驾驶证，
She had never had it easy. The stuff that I went to when I was little, it taught me my survival skills. Deletia's family was poor growing up. Both of her parents struggled with addiction, and she had her first kid at 16. I didn't get a chance to enjoy my teenage years, because I was a mom. There were so many obstacles and so much instability in Deletia's life, but somehow by the time she was in her 30s, she'd managed to get her GED, her forklifting license,
以及伯克利农场牛奶厂（Berkeley Farms Milk Plant）一份待遇优厚、有福利的工会工作。但随后事情开始瓦解。感觉就像是一个家庭危机接着另一个家庭危机。我在情感上经历了很多，然后我妈妈，她生病了，在吸毒，进出医院，事情发展到我真的，我累了，凯蒂。蒂莉丝开始旷工在工厂上班。
and a good union job with benefits at Berkeley Farms Milk Plant. But then things started to unravel. It felt like there was one family crisis after another. I just went through a lot emotionally and then my mom, she was sick and using drugs and in and out of hospital and it just got to the point where I was just, I was tired Katie. Tileisha started missing work at the plant.
最终她失去了工作，不久之后失去了公寓。2014年，她无家可归了。有一段时间，她和乔丹找到了可以借宿的地方，她也断断续续地做着临时工作，但他们在一个地方呆不了太久。你知道，有些人的生活方式和你以前习惯的不同。有些人很脏，有些人很干净。
Eventually she lost her job and shortly thereafter her apartment. In 2014 she became homeless. For a while, she and Jordan found places to crash and she worked temp jobs on and off, but they could only stay in one place for so long. You know, some people live different from how you used to live in. Some people are dirty, some people are clean.
有些人很脏，有些很干净，有些人嗑药而你不嗑药。有的人会说，你来这里呆几天，你给他们一些钱，你吃东西等等，然后在那之后他们行为变得奇怪，或者觉得他们想要自己的空间就把你赶出去。他们在某个地方呆上几个月或几个星期，然后就到了该搬家的时候了。岁月就这样流逝。最终，这种不稳定开始消磨蒂莉丝的心理健康。因为无家可归，从心理上讲，是个麻烦。尤其是当你孩子问你的时候。
Some people are dirty, some people are clean, some people get high and you don't get high. Somebody be like, you come over here for a few days, you get them some money, you eat and stuff and then after that they act funny or feel like they want their space and put you out. They'd stay somewhere for a few months or a few weeks and then it would be time to move on. Years passed like this. Eventually, the instability started to wear on Tilly's mental health. Because being homeless, mentally, is trouble. Especially when your child acts you.
当你接他们放学时，妈妈，我们要去哪里？妈妈，我们要去哪里吃东西？蒂莉丝觉得自己就像在踩水，勉强浮在水面上。或者也许她根本没有浮在水面上，而是在慢慢溺水。她急需一个救生筏。但她生活里没有谁稳定到能让她抓得住。她周围的每个人也都在苦苦挣扎。我到了那种地步，我真的在试图弄清楚
When you pick them up from school, mom, where are we gonna go? Mom, where are we gonna eat? Tileja felt like she was treading water, just barely staying afloat. Or maybe she wasn't staying afloat at all, it was actually slowly drowning. She desperately needed a life raft. But there was no one stable enough in her life to grab onto. Everyone around her was also struggling. I was to the point where I was really trying to figure out
我可以把我的儿子安置在哪里，我无法为他提供等待的条件。我想让一个亲戚照顾他一段时间。你知道他在哪里可以吃、睡、洗澡、保持干净、无烟和防火，但你没有那种东西。我能想象或找出一个人。2018年，在经历了四年的四处流浪
where can I place and put my son that I can't provide for him to wait. I want to let a family member have him for a while. You know where he could eat, sleep, bathe, be clean, smoke-free, and fire, but you don't stuff like that. And I could picture or figure out one person. In 2018, after four years of bouncing around
从一个地方到另一个地方之后，蒂莉丝精神崩溃了。有几个月，她产生了一种妄想，觉得自己既有名又富有，当别人试图说服她并非如此时，她会变得具有攻击性。当我开始做一些我通常不做的事情时。那时我知道我需要帮助。在这期间，当她独自开车时，
from place to place, Tilecia suffered a psychotic break. For a couple of months, she had delusions that she was famous and wealthy, and she got aggressive when people tried to convince her otherwise. When I started doing stuff, I don't usually do. That's when I knew I need a help. During this time, while she was driving by herself,
蒂莉丝故意把车撞向一面墙。她并不想死。这更像是一种寻求帮助的呼喊。我对自己说，如果我撞上那个电线杆，我会死的。如果我撞上那堵砖墙，我可以活下来，但我会受伤的。所以我说，管他电线杆，我直接转动了方向盘。撞车后，蒂莉丝去了普通医院
Tilecia crashed her car on purpose into a wall. She didn't want to die. It was more like a cry for help. And I said to myself, if I hit that pole, I'm gonna die. If I hit that brick wall, I can survive, but I'm gonna be f***ing. So I said, let the pole and I just turn the wheel. After the crash, Tileja went to a regular hospital
然后去了一家精神病院，在那里她被诊断患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）等疾病。然后，就像她一直以来所做的那样，她挣扎着回到了某种脆弱的理智状态。这就把我们带到了2019年，当时蒂莉丝和乔丹仍然无家可归，已经耗尽了每一个家人或朋友的联系。除了车，已经无处可去了。汽车是神圣的。蒂莉丝把钥匙挂在脖子上的挂绳上。如果不是因为这辆车，她告诉我他们就会住在桥底下。
and then a psychiatric hospital, where she was diagnosed with PTSD among other things. And then, like she's always done, she clawed her way back to some fragile semblance of sanity. And that brings us to 2019, when Tleisha and Jordan still homeless had exhausted every last family or friend connection. There was nowhere left to go except for the car. The car is sacred. Tilly show wears her keys on a lanyard around her neck. If it wasn't for the car, she tells me they'd be living under a bridge.
我只是把座位放倒，把我的小东西盖在前窗上。我们吃零食和我们吃的其他东西，盖上被子，我们就去睡觉。嗯，亚历克斯，杀了。祝你好运。不。为什么？这不是杀了我。你绝对不可能躺下。
I just put my seat back, put my little thing to cover up the front window. We'll have our snacks and whatever else we eat, our cover, and we'll just go to sleep. Um, Alex, kill me. Good luck. Nope. Why? It's not a kill me. There's no way you're laying.
哦，太紧了。我们可以去后座。我们可以靠近树木。如果我做噩梦的话。夏天就这样过去了。脖子和背部僵硬，睡在车里，在麦当劳洗脸。但是后来，当学年开始时，
Oh, it's tight. We can get in the back seat. We can get by the trees. If I go in a bad dream. That's how the summer rolled forward. Stiff necks and backs, sleeping in the car, washing their faces at McDonald's. But then, when the school year starts,
发生了一件简直不可思议的事。蒂莉丝终于得到了一个救生筏。她的名字叫特里什·安德森（Trish Anderson）。嗯-huh。保佑你，姑娘，继续加油。好的。YouTube，拜拜。有一天。好的，但她拜拜。有一天。
something kind of incredible happens. Tilecia finally gets a life raft. Her name is Trish Anderson. Uh-huh. Bless you girl, keep it up. Okay. YouTube, bye bye. One day. Okay, but she bye bye. One day.
好的，但她呆了一个小时。你知道吗，因为我不知道美国每个学区都有一个人，其工作就是帮助无家可归的家庭？特里什·安德森就是奥克兰的那个人。她的头衔，麦金尼-文托联络员（McKinney-Vento liaison），来自设立这个职位的联邦立法。特里什的办公室在小学后面的一座小活动板房里。她身上戴着大约一打手镯，当她说话时，手镯在桌子上叮当作响。她允许我在电子邮件和电话之间采访她。嗨，莱斯利，我是特里什。
Okay, but she does one hour. Did you know because I did not know that every school district in the US has a person whose job is to help homeless families? Trish Anderson is that person in Oakland. Her title, the McKinney-Vento liaison, comes from the federal legislation that established the position. Trisha's office is in a little portable building behind an elementary school. She has about a dozen bracelets on her tris that clank on the table when she talks. And she lets me interview her between emails and phone calls. Hi Leslie, this is Trisha.
嗨，莱斯利，我有个情况。我有一个妈妈和一个女儿。她们不在车里。她们无处可去。所以妈妈为我搬到了这里。在2017-2018学年期间，公立学校的数据显示，全国有大约一百五十万名学生经历过无家可归。
Hi, so Leslie, I have a situation. I have a mom and a daughter. They're not in a car. They have no place to go. So mom moved here for me. Over the course of the 2017-2018 school year, public school data shows that some one and a half million students experienced homelessness across the country.
这些学生往往跟随父母从城镇的一个地方搬到另一个地方，再搬到另一个地方。麦金尼-文托联络员工作的一个重要部分就是帮助无家可归的父母为他们的孩子办理学校入学和重新入学手续。特里什做了很多这方面的工作，但她还可以提供公交卡和校服等方面的帮助。有时当我离开时他们不想要，或者我不需要交通工具，我需要一个房子。我的意思是这是真的。特里什不能提供实质意义上的住房，尽管她可以帮助父母填写
These students tend to move with their parents from one part of town to another to another. And a big part of the McKinney-Vento liaison's job is helping homeless parents enroll and re-enroll their kids in school. Trish does a lot of that, but she can also help with things like bus passes and uniforms. Sometimes they don't want one when I off, or I don't need transportation, I need a house. And I mean that's real. Trish can't offer housing per se, although she can help parents fill out applications
公寓申请表或在互联网上寻找负担得起的地方。当她项目中的一个家庭最终找到住房或庇护所时，他们会得到一个小建筑纸房子贴在墙上。所以这个，有人从车里搬到了庇护所。所以她装饰了她自己的。任何进展我们都不会忽视。特里什有着热情洋溢的性格，但内心深处也有某种防备。当我问她是否把工作带回家时，她说她尽量不这样做。她自己家里也有问题。
for apartments or search for affordable places on the internet. When a family and her program finally finds housing or shelter, they get a little construction paper house to put on the wall. So this one, someone went from car to shelter. So she decorated hers. Any movement we ignore. Trish has a big warm personality, but there's also something guarded underneath. When I ask her if she ever takes work home, she says she tries not to. She has her own problems at home.
她是照顾患有精神分裂症的儿子的主要照顾者，还要照顾年迈、需要大量日常事务帮助的母亲。但偶尔地，会有人突破她的防御网。蒂莉丝就是这样的人。特里什记得在学年开始时看到蒂莉丝，她来为乔丹领公交卡。她斜靠在椅子上，戴着帽子，看起来非常疲惫。所以我说，每天都来。每天都来，吃燕麦片，闲逛，当志愿者，帮我整理衣柜。
She's a caregiver for her son who skits a friend and for her elderly mother who needs a lot of help with day-to-day tasks. But every now and again, someone slips past her force field. Tullisha was like that. Trisha remembers seeing Tullisha at the beginning of the school year, and she came to pick up a bus pass for Jordan. She was slid down in the chair, had on a hat, looked very tired. So I said, come here every day. Come here every day, have oatmeal hang out, volunteer, help me with my closet.
我当时想，好吧。我也这么说的。我当时想，好吧，其实我开始每天都去，每天都去。我吃燕麦片，吃东西，上网，寻找资源。在蒂莉丝在那里的同时，特里什也鼓励她做另一件事。她有一段时间没尝试过的事情。
I was like, okay. That's what I said, too. I was like, okay, actually I start going every day, every day. I have oatmeal, eat, get on a computer, look for resources. And while Tileisha was there, Trish encouraged her to do something else too. Something she hadn't tried in a while.
拨打211并寻求帮助。211是面向在阿拉米达县寻求庇护或住房等帮助的无家可归者的求助热线。非常感谢您的拨打。今天我能为您做些什么？是的，我和我11岁的儿子无家可归。你和你儿子一直睡在哪里？你住在哪里？或者昨晚睡在哪里？在我那辆开不了的车里。
Call 211 and ask for help. 211 is a kind of hotline for homeless people who are looking for help with things like shelter or housing in Alameda County. Thank you so much for hoping. How can I assist you today? Yes, me and my 11-year-old son is home. And where have you and your son been sleeping? Where did you stay at? Or sleep last night? In my car that don't run.
拨打 211 寻求帮助。211 是一个热线电话，专门为阿拉米达县寻找避难所或住房等帮助的无家可归者服务。非常感谢您的期望。今天我能为您提供什么帮助？是的，我和我 11 岁的儿子在家。你和儿子一直睡在哪里？你们昨晚呆在哪里？或者睡在哪里？在我那辆坏了的车里。
Okay. So tomorrow you can go at 1pm at the Henry Robinson Multi-Service Center to do an assessment for the CES program. When the operator says the CES program, she's using an acronym for the coordinated entry system. You're going to understand a lot more about this system by the end of this series. But for now, I'll just say that most communities in the US have a system like this. And one thing it does is create a big master list of homeless people that all the nonprofits in a particular community are working off of. This helps to ensure that two different organizations aren't trying to assist the same person without knowing it. Anyway, the operator is telling Tilly Shows she needs to get into this system in order to get help with housing. And that, unfortunately, there are no shelters to stay in in the meantime.
好吧。所以明天下午1点你可以去亨利·罗宾逊多服务中心，为“协同准入系统”（CES项目）做一个评估。当接线员说CES项目时，她用的是“协同准入系统”的缩写。听完这个系列节目后，你会对这个系统有更多的了解。但现在，我只想说，美国大多数社区都有这样的系统。它的作用之一是建立一个全美无家可归人员的庞大主名单，特定社区里的所有非营利组织都在依据这个名单开展工作。这有助于确保不会出现两个不同的组织在不知情的情况下同时尝试帮助同一个人的情况。不管怎样，接线员在告诉泰莉莎·肖（Tilly Shows），她需要进入这个系统才能获得住房方面的帮助。而不幸的是，在此期间没有收容所可以入住。
There was no mom with child to be able to play now. Then I'm just trying to find something before it rains. Yeah, yeah, it's a little bit. Okay. Okay. All right. Thank you. All right. Thank you for calling. Bye-bye. The next day, Tleysha took the bus to the nonprofit in downtown Oakland that the operator had told her about. While she waited, she eyed the other people who were also there. Everyone homeless, everyone in need. Eventually, it was Tilecia's turn,
现在没有带着孩子的妈妈能去玩了。然后我只是想在下雨前找个地方。好吧，好吧。行。谢谢。好啦。谢谢你的来电。再见。第二天，泰莉莎坐公交车来到了奥克兰市中心的那家非营利组织，接线员曾跟她提过这里。在她等待的时候，她打量着也在那里的其他人。每个人都无家可归，每个人都需要帮助。终于轮到泰莉莎了，
and she answered some questions with a social worker named Yolanda. What is your monthly income, Yolanda asked her? $836, Tilecia answered. Tilecia didn't have a job at the time, but she got some money from the state because of Jordan's disability. Does anyone in your household suffer from depression? Yes.
她和一位名叫约兰达（Yolanda）的社工回答了一些问题。“你的月收入是多少？”约兰达问她。“836美元，”泰莉莎回答。泰莉莎当时没有工作，但因为乔丹的残疾，她从州里领到了一些钱。“你家里有人患有抑郁症吗？”“是的。”
In the past 30 days have you had to do things that felt unsafe to survive? Yes. How often? Daily. There were more questions, and Yolanda entered Tilecia's answers into a computer while they talked. The fact that they wanted to know so much about her seemed like a good sign to Tilecia. She felt hopeful even though they were still sleeping in the car. It's so loud.
“在过去的30天里，你有没有为了生存而不得不做一些感觉不安全的事情？”“是的。”“频率是多少？”“每天。”还有更多问题，在交谈时，约兰达把泰莉莎的回答输入了一台电脑。他们想对她了解得这么多，在泰莉莎看来似乎是个好迹象。尽管他们仍然睡在车里，她还是感到了一丝希望。声音太大了。
What? So what's your favorite food? Spaghetti's chicken and garlic bread with some salad, fish, French fries and salad, tea balls, steak, potatoes. Mmm-mmm. A roast. Mmm. With a laksa of guinea.
什么？那你最喜欢的食物是什么？意大利面、鸡肉和大蒜面包加点沙拉、鱼、炸薯条加沙拉、茶球、牛排、土豆。嗯——嗯。烤肉。嗯。配上吉尼拉克沙。
with a likes of Keeney. Hmm. Yeah. What's your favorite dessert? You like banana pudding? Now a chocolate cake. Chocolate cake. As cream cake? Ice cream cake.
配上吉尼拉克沙。嗯。对。你最喜欢的甜点是什么？你喜欢香蕉布丁吗？现在是巧克力蛋糕。巧克力蛋糕。冰淇淋蛋糕？冰淇淋蛋糕。
As queen cake ice cream cake cupcake is some Sunny Sunday, oh another some Sunday Well, Tolisha waited to hear back that whether she was gonna get hope with housing or shelter She kept going to see Trish It's interesting with Tolisha because you try to have boundaries.
作为冰淇淋蛋糕纸杯蛋糕是一些桑尼星期天，哦，另一个是一些星期天。好吧，在等待关于她是否能获得住房或收容所救助的回复期间，泰莉莎一直去找特里什（Trish）。和泰莉莎在一起很有意思，因为你试着去划定界限。
And there's always one or two or a few, and I have a few where the boundary, it's really hard to keep that boundary because there's something else they need or they draw it on you. And she demanded it. And it happened. It just happened that way.
总有一两个或者几个，而我有几个界限，真的很难去坚守那个界限，因为她们还有其他需要，或者她们把你拉了进去。而她提出了这个要求。事情就这样发生了。事情就是这样发生的。
And not everybody does that. It wasn't that long before Tilecia started calling Trish big mama and telling her she loved her. The two of them recounted this to me in Trish's office. Like people don't come in and say, I love you. You know what I'm saying? And then I found myself saying it back because she needed it.
并不是每个人都会这样做。没过多久，泰莉莎就开始叫特里什“大妈妈”，并告诉她自己爱她。两人在特里什的办公室里向我回忆了这件事。“人们不会走进来就说‘我爱你’。你知道我在说什么吗？”然后我发现自己也回了一句，因为她需要这个。
So that was the demand. She wasn't going gonna accept anything less. I started saying it because I wanna her to know, you know, I really, I do love her. You're getting emotional. Of course I'm always getting emotional. I'm being emotional, creature. I know this side of Tilecia too.
所以这就是她的要求。她绝不接受任何少于这个的要求。我开始说这句话是因为我想让她知道，你知道的，我是真的爱她。你情绪激动了。我当然总是情绪激动。我很情绪激动，克里特。我也了解泰莉莎的这一面。
I've tried to keep a journalistic boundary with her, but she texts me out of the blue like, hey Katie, what are you doing? Or she'd say, I'm sad, and I'd find myself giving her a pep talk. Another case in point. For some reason, at this very moment in Trisha's office, she was squeezed onto the same chair as me. I'm just squeezed onto the chair with you, I don't know, there's this whole other chair right there. Sorry. See? See?
我曾试图与她保持记者和采访对象的界限，但她会冷不丁地发短信给我，比如“嘿，凯蒂，你在干嘛？”或者她会说“我很伤心”，然后我发现自己在一边给她加油打气。又一个例证。出于某种原因，就在此时此刻在特里什的办公室里，她和我挤在同一把椅子上。“我和你挤在一把椅子上，我不知道，旁边明明还有整整一把椅子。对不起。看？看？”
I just sold the man. Yeah, you can't keep a belt. I'm sorry. Yeah, I'm sorry. With Trisha's support and a place to be every day, Telisha was finally in an emotional state where she felt like she could work again. Andrish encouraged her to apply to a temp agency. She did, and she got a temporary position in washing dishes for Cirque du Soleil. In the evenings of Tullisha had enough money,
我刚刚把那个人卖了。是啊，你留不住皮带。我很抱歉。是的，我很抱歉。在特里什的支持以及每天都有个去处的情况下，泰莉莎终于调整好了情绪状态，觉得可以再次工作了。特里什鼓励她去一家临时工机构申请工作。她照做了，并在太阳马戏团（Cirque du Soleil）找到了一份洗碗的临时工作。到了晚上，如果泰莉莎有足够的钱，
she'd buy herself in Jordan something to eat for dinner, and Jordan would spread his home workout on the table at KFC or McDonald's. Sometimes she'd even have enough money to do something fun like a movie. They were still sleeping in the car, but it felt like maybe things were turning around. I need a county to help my head can I help you? A couple weeks after that first call, Tileisha tried to and won again. Good morning. How you doing? Good thing you're having a good time. If you guys have any rooms for rent on your listing or any traditional housing. Okay, just give me a second please. Don't hang out. Okay.
她会给自己和乔丹买点晚饭吃，而乔丹则会把他的家庭作业摊在肯德基或麦当劳的桌子上。有时候她甚至会有足够的钱去做点有趣的事，比如看场电影。他们仍然睡在车里，但感觉事情似乎在好转。我需要一个县来帮我清醒一下，能帮帮我吗？在那次第一通电话的几周后，泰莉莎再次尝试并打通了电话。早安。你好吗？很高兴你过得不错。如果你们的房源列表里有任何待出租的房间，或者任何传统住房。好的，请等一下。别挂机。好的。
And are you by yourself? I have an 11 year old son with a disability. Okay. The operator asked Tilly Shoe if she'd already done an assessment for the coordinated entry system. She said she had other than referring people into that system where maybe hopefully they'll get assistance with housing. 211 also maintains their own database of subsidized housing options that you don't have to be homeless to get into. Just poor. But all of those options have waiting lists.
只有你一个人吗？我有一个11岁患有残疾的儿子。好的。接线员问泰莉莎是否已经为“协同准入系统”做过评估。她说她做过了。除了将人们转介到该系统——希望他们能在那里获得住房援助之外，211还维护着自己的补贴住房选项数据库，进入这些选项并不需要你无家可归，只需要你贫困。但所有这些选项都有等待名单。
The waiting list is from one to five years. That's the problem. They can also give you a list of apartments on the private market that aren't subsidized, but where the landlords might be willing to work with tenants that have less than sparkling rental histories. But there doesn't seem to be much of anything that would be affordable for Tilecia. OK, there is one. Is this a room for rent in Auckland? The price is 600 per person. So you have to be 1,200 per room.
等待名单是一到五年。这就是问题所在。他们还可以为你提供一份私人市场上的公寓名单，这些公寓没有补贴，但房东可能愿意与租房历史不够光鲜的租客合作。但似乎没有什么东西是泰莉莎能够负担得起的。好吧，有一个。这是奥克兰的一间出租房吗？价格是每人600美元。所以一个房间得1200美元。
You can tell the operator thinks 1,200 for a room is an absolute garbage option. To my child. I mean, for my own room, no, I try to figure it out. It is a little bit expensive, but all we need is our own room. Tolisha told me later she didn't end up pursuing that room. It was too expensive. Before they hang up, Tolisha asks me later she didn't end up pursuing that room. It was too expensive. Before they hang up, Tolisha asks again about shelter.
你可以看出接线员觉得一个房间1200美元简直是个烂透了的选择。为了我的孩子。我是说，为了我自己的房间，不，我试着去弄清楚。这确实有点贵，但我们需要的只是我们自己的房间。泰莉莎后来告诉我，她最后并没有去租那个房间。太贵了。在挂断电话之前，泰莉莎后来告诉我她最后并没有去租那个房间。太贵了。在挂断电话之前，泰莉莎再次询问有关收容所的事。
The operator tells her that the only thing available is for victims of domestic violence. And then asks her, and a tone that can only be described as hopeful if she happens to be one. Yeah, first of all, are you a victim of domestic violence? In my past, but not recently, actually. Right now. Are you a victim of domestic violence? In my parents, but not recently, I think. Yeah, unfortunately, there is nothing available right now. Trish told me she tells all of her homeless parents to call 2-on-1. But for most of them, it doesn't lead to housing.
接线员告诉她，唯一可用的收容所是为家庭暴力受害者准备的。然后用一种只能被形容为充满希望的语气问她，她是否恰好是其中一员。对，首先，你是家庭暴力受害者吗？我的过去是，但最近不是，实际上。现在。你是家庭暴力受害者吗？在我的父母那里，但不是最近，我想。是的，不幸的是，现在没有什么可用的。特里什告诉我，她让她所有的无家可归的父母都去打211。但对他们大多数人来说，这并不能带来住房。
Which, she doesn't think it's 2-on-1's fault. But for most of them, it doesn't lead to housing, which she doesn't think it's two on one's fault, but it's still frustrating. Every time you call, you're getting the same interview over and over and over again, and it's like they're collecting all this data, but there's no movement. What's a case that's really stuck with you, you know, without naming names, but like, the mom who says, if I don't find housing this year, I'm gonna kill myself. And my kids will be better off without me because at least they'll go in the foster care
她认为这并不是211的错。但对他们大多数人来说，这并不能带来住房，她认为这并不是211的错，但这仍然令人沮丧。每次你打电话，你都在一遍又一遍、没完没了地接受同一次采访，就好像他们一直在收集所有这些数据，但却没有任何进展。哪一个案例最让你记忆犹新，你知道的，不指名道姓，但就像，那个妈妈说，如果我今年找不到住房，我就要自杀。我的孩子们没有我会过得更好，因为至少他们会进入寄养系统，
and they'll get housed into the, I had two attempted suicide slides last year. No, this year, I never saw that before. So the mental health has really been on the decline for these families. The story's Trish hears all day from these parents are hard. She tells me while she bangs out a few emails, how she manages to hold so many sad stories. Well, my faith is what makes me have more, the most capacity to do the work. I'm not going to look as personally.
他们会住进……我去年经历了两次自杀未遂。不，是今年，我以前从未见过这种情况。所以这些家庭的心理健康确实一直在下滑。特里什整天从这些父母那里听到的故事都很艰难。她一边飞快地敲击着几封电子邮件，一边告诉我她是如何应付这么多悲伤的故事的。嗯，我的信仰让我拥有了做这项工作最多、最大的承受力。我不会把它看得太个人化。
I don't know what it feels like to have faith drive you like that. Well it's just a place to put it all so you don't carry it. All the things you can't solve, all the things you can't carry because you got to carry something else. It's a place like you know you're purse, you put all your things you can't solve, all the things you can't carry because you got to carry something else. It's a place like, you know, you're purse, you put all your things you need for the day and the purse or a bag or the, it's kind of like that. And so you're able to carry more. Still, Trish says the purse is filling up and she's not sure how much more it or she can carry. Yeah, you can't do this forever.
我不知道被信仰这样驱动是什么感觉。嗯，这只是一个地方，可以把所有东西都放下，这样你就不用背着它们了。所有你无法解决的事情，所有你无法承受的事情，因为你必须去承受别的事情。这就像一个地方，你知道的，你的钱包，你把你所有无法解决的事情，所有你无法承受的事情都放进去，因为你必须去承受别的事情。这就像一个地方，你知道的，你的钱包，你把你一天中需要的所有东西都放进钱包、包里，或者……有点像那样。所以你就能够承受更多。尽管如此，特里什说钱包快满了，她不确定它或她自己还能承受多少。是的，你不可能永远这样下去。
I've done it for a long time already. Part of what's hard for Trish is that she doesn't feel like she has as much power as she is to make a difference in people's lives. A couple of years ago, Trish could help the family she worked with get into shelters. If she had a family walk in at 4 p.m., who had nowhere to sleep that night,
我已经做这行很长时间了。对特里什来说，困难的一部分在于她觉得自己在改变人们的生活方面并没有那么大的权力。几年前，特里什可以帮她合作的家庭住进收容所。如果她在下午4点遇到一个无处可归的家庭，当天晚上没有地方睡觉，
she'd start making calls. But then the county shifted to a system where everyone has to go through 2-1-1. And now she can't do that anymore. It's hard to notice someone's on the street, you can't make a phone call and get them into a shelter. You know, in this position you have to be careful that you don't become a complainer. Because you're having families interact with a system that you don't think is it works or it has challenges and the families are already feeling that. So you walk a fine line in your frustration. This call was the last time Tilly should try to one one. It's about three weeks from her first call, and she sounds tired. The operator tells her that the only shelters available are for single adults, not for a woman with a 3.0 on his report card, you know.
她就会开始打电话。但后来县里转向了一个系统，每个人都必须通过211。现在她再也做不到这一点了。很难注意到有人流落街头，却不能打个电话让他们住进收容所。你知道，在这个职位上，你必须小心，不要让自己变成一个爱抱怨的人。因为你要让家庭与一个你认为并不管用或存在问题的系统进行互动，而这些家庭已经感受到了这一点。所以在你的沮丧情绪中，你必须走钢丝。这通电话是泰莉莎最后一次尝试打211。距离她第一次打电话大约三周了，她听起来很累。接线员告诉她，唯一可用的收容所是为单身成年人准备的，而不是为了一个成绩单上有3.0分的孩子的母亲，你知道的。
Oh, he's running out of power at the school. Yeah, he's doing really good and stuff. I don't want to stop all that stuff that he's got going on. Just jumping in here to say that Tilecia is right to be worried about Jordan falling behind academically. Data from public schools in 2017-2018 showed that only 29% of homeless students were proficient in reading, and they were similarly behind in math. But it isn't just poverty that makes them slip, it's instability. Homeless kids' test scores are below even other low-income students who are stably housed. Before they get off the phone, the operator suggests that we should get into the coordinated entry system, not seeming to realize that she was already in the system. She'd been in it for weeks now. She hadn't gotten any help.
哦，他在学校里的精力快用完了。是的，他表现得真的很好之类。我不想阻止他一直在做的所有那些事。插播一句，泰莉莎担心乔丹在学业上掉队是正确的。2017-2018年公立学校的数据显示，只有29%的无家可归学生的阅读能力达到熟练水平，他们在数学方面的落后情况也与之类似。但导致他们滑落的不仅仅是贫困，还有不稳定性。无家可归孩子的考试成绩甚至低于那些有稳定住所的其他低收入学生。在挂断电话之前，接线员建议我们应该加入协同准入系统，似乎没有意识到她其实已经在这个系统里了。她已经在里面待了好几个星期了。她没有得到任何帮助。
Like, nobody never called me back and checked on me. Like, I've been going through this now for so long. And what do you think that is? There's so many people all over that experience. The same thing as me. Everybody just never got to me on the list. I just feel like somebody somebody they forgot about me. They forgot about me and my son.
就像，从来没有人给我回过电话并查看我的情况。就像，我经历这一切已经这么久了。你觉得这是为什么呢？周围有那么多的人都有着和我一样的经历。大家只是从来没有轮到我。我只是觉得有人……有人把我给忘了。他们把我跟我的儿子给忘了。
In other words, for Tullisha, the fact that help never came wasn't personal and it totally was personal. A couple months after those two-on-one calls, Tullisha still hadn't gotten any help with housing from the system. She had a new job at Napa Auto Parts, where she made about $500 a week, but she hadn't been able to save much yet. She had found a spot where she and Jordan could stay inside with some regularity, not their own place, but somewhere to crash at least. It didn't feel like home though,
换句话说，对泰莉莎来说，帮助从未到来这件事既不是针对个人的，又完全是针对个人的。在打了那两通211电话几个月后，泰莉莎仍然没有从系统中获得任何住房方面的帮助。她在纳帕汽车零部件公司（Napa Auto Parts）找到了一份新工作，每周能赚大约500美元，但她还没能存下多少钱。她找到了一个她和乔丹可以经常待在室内的地方，虽然不是他们自己的地方，但至少有个可以栖身的地方。不过感觉不像是家，
even though she had a roof over her head. She still felt homeless. There's nothing else for me to do, but keep trying. Yeah. I think about Jordan more than I think about myself. Every night, I just keep listening to that song. Oh, don't change this coming.
尽管她头上有了遮风挡雨的屋顶。她仍然觉得自己无家可归。我没有什么别的事可做，只能继续坚持。是的。我想乔丹比我想自己还要多。每天晚上，我只是不停地听那首歌。哦，改变就要来临了。
And I just keep holding on. Everything gon' be our righteous hold on. Changes coming. I'm on it right now though, like right right now. Thanks for talking to me. Thank you. Always appreciate it. Yep, I feel better too.
而我一直在坚持。一切都会好起来的，坚持住。改变就要来临了。我现在就在经历这一切，就是现在。谢谢你跟我聊天。谢谢你。一直都很感激。是的，我也感觉好多了。
Oh good. I feel like I wore you out, but I'm going. I was already wore out. Yeah. Before you got in there. All right, well, I hope you get some good sleep tonight. I don't know if so too. That's also true. The place where Tullisha and Jordan were staying was a one bedroom basement apartment where
哦，太好了。我觉得我把你累坏了，不过我要走了。我已经累坏了。是的。在你进来之前。好吧，嗯，希望你今晚能睡个好觉。我不知道是不是也这样。这也是真的。泰莉莎和乔丹暂住的地方是一个一室一厅的地下室公寓，
a bunch of other people also lived. One guy slept on the couch, another person slept in a recliner. Tullisha and Jordan slept on a barermatras. Sometimes there were tensions in the house, though. People mad at each other over bills or food or what to watch on TV. And then Tilecia and Jordan would end up back in the one place they'd always been able to count on. The car. That's his stars. His stars?
里面还住着好几个人。一个人睡在沙发上，另一个人睡在躺椅上。泰莉莎和乔丹睡在一张泡沫床垫上。不过，屋里有时会有紧张气氛。人们因为账单、食物或看电视看什么而彼此生气。然后泰莉莎和乔丹最后又回到了他们一直可以依靠的唯一地方。那辆车。那是他的星星。他的星星？
Yeah. I want to see. Ah, more. Yeah. That was so sweet, but it does. You feel sorry for the dinosaurs? Yeah, they speak. I won't do. dinosaurs yeah the stink all the dinosaurs go to the other to saw the pink rats I think some of them not go? Yeah. Well, they're in the cage, hibernating.
是的。我想看。啊，更多。是的。太甜了，不过确实是这样。你为恐龙感到遗憾吗？是的，它们灭绝了。我不会的。恐龙，是的，它们臭气熏天，所有的恐龙都去另一边看到了粉红色的老鼠。我想有些没有去吗？是的。嗯，它们在笼子里，在冬眠。
Maybe, yeah. I wanted to understand why Tullisha had never gotten any help with housing. Who was this system helping if not her? One thing I did know was that when homeless people wanted help, they were almost always advised to call 2-1-1. That seemed to be the starting place for everyone. If I wanted to understand how this all worked, maybe I should pay them a visit. That's next time on According to Need. Coming up, I continue my conversation with Katie Mingle, and we get an update on Tuleasha
也许吧，是的。我想了解为什么泰莉莎从未获得任何住房方面的帮助。如果不是她，这个系统究竟在帮助谁呢？我确实知道的一件事是，当无家可归的人想要寻求帮助时，他们几乎总是被建议拨打211。这似乎是每个人的起点。如果我想了解这一切是如何运作的，也许我应该去拜访他们一下。这是下一期的《按需分配》。接下来，我将继续与凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）对话，我们将获得关于泰莉莎的最新消息。
after this. We're back with the award-winning Katie Mingle producer of According to Need. Can you give us an update on the people in this episode or any stuff that's happened since we published the series? Yeah, I mean, I can give you an update on Tilly's show, for sure. If you listen all the way to the end of the series, you will hear that Tilly's show doesn't end up getting help from the system in the Bay Area, or not like significant help, that is kind of like life changing help,
广告过后，我们将迎来《按需分配》的获奖制作人凯蒂·明格。你能给我们更新一下本期节目中的人物，或者自从我们发布这个系列以来发生的事情吗？是的，我的意思是，我肯定可以向你更新泰莉莎的情况。如果你一直听到这个系列的结尾，你就会听说泰莉莎最终并没有从湾区的系统中获得帮助，或者说没有获得重大的帮助，也就是那种能改变人生的帮助，
but she does end up getting section eight, which was sort of luck in a way, like she had put her name on some section eight wait lists years ago, like it had been like eight years since she put her name on these wait lists and apparently you can put your name on wait lists wherever there's section eight vouchers open and you know that might not even be the city you live in. It might be some random city that you've never been to which was the case for her and she got section eight in Louisville, Kentucky. And then after like a lot of really hard
但她最终拿到了第8类住房券（Section 8），这在某种程度上算是一种运气，比如她几年前就把自己的名字写在了几个第8类住房券的等待名单上，当时距离她把名字写在这些等待名单上已经过去了大约八年，显然你可以在任何有第8类住房券名额的地方把名字写在等待名单上，你知道那甚至可能不是你居住的城市。它可能是某个你从未去过随机城市，对她来说就是这种情况，她在肯塔基州路易斯维尔获得了第8类住房券。然后经过一番非常艰难的
thinking and sort of going back and forth and a ton of just like anxiety and sort of stressing out, she decided she was going to try to go for this housing in Louisville, Kentucky, a place where she had never been and didn't know anyone. And that was a really big decision. I mean, I say this in the update at the end of the show, but like, I rarely met people who were thinking about leaving because people are just so dependent on their communities and their families and stuff for support. I think particularly people in poverty are just really, really leaning on the people around them for help.
思考、反复权衡，以及海量的焦虑和压力之后，她决定去争取肯塔基州路易斯维尔的这套住房，那是一个她从未去过且人生地不熟的地方。那是一个非常重大的决定。我的意思是，我在节目末尾的更新中说过，但是，我很少遇到那些考虑离开的人，因为人们太依赖他们的社区和家人等来获取支持了。我认为特别是处于贫困中的人们，真的非常非常依赖周围的人来获得帮助。
And so the idea that you would move somewhere or where you didn't know anyone is just something that most people I met wouldn't even consider. But yeah, it's really just decided to take this big leap, move out there. It was really, really hard at first. And the section eight, the process of actually getting a house was not entirely smooth. But she got a place. She's been in that place for almost two years now.
所以，你要搬到一个你谁也不认识的地方的想法，是大多数我遇到的人甚至都不会考虑的。但是，是的，她真的只是决定迈出这一大步，搬到那里去。起初真的非常非常艰难。而且第8类住房券，实际获得房屋的过程也并非一帆风顺。但她找到了一处住所。她已经在那个地方住了快两年了。
She is doing really well. She got a job, she got a full-time job at Walmart. For a little while, she was working two jobs. I think she quit her second job. She bought a car. She recently went on a cruise, which I know like, what a cruise is, I thought they were kind of over forever,
她现在过得很好。她找到了一份工作，在沃尔玛（Walmart）找到了一份全职工作。有一段时间，她同时打两份工。我想她辞掉了第二份工作。她买了一辆车。她最近去游轮度假了，我知道，什么游轮啊，我以为那种旅行方式早就过时了，
but they came back and she went on a cruise like right around Christmas time. So she's doing great except for you know she has family back in Oakland that she misses and who you know are still struggling in some ways to just like get by and live in the Bay Area, which was like the struggle that she was in too for a while, but now she's kind of gotten a little relief from that, which is not to say that life is easy because it isn't, but it's a lot better.
但它们又回归了，就在圣诞节前后，她去坐了游轮。所以她过得很棒，除了你知道的，她有家人在奥克兰，她很想念他们，而且你知道的，他们在某些方面还在苦苦挣扎，勉强维生，住在湾区——这也是她曾经经历过的挣扎，但现在她总算从中得到了一些解脱，这并不是说生活变得容易了，因为它并没有，但确实好多了。
It's a lot better. That's so amazing to hear. Yeah. I love that. So you reported this for two years. It came out while you were reporting it, the very tail end of it, a COVID happened, which had a huge impact on the homeless population. And so do you know what's going on now in terms of COVID and homelessness and how that's
好多了。听到这个真是太棒了。是的。我太喜欢这样了。所以你报道这个花了两年时间。它在你报道期间播出了，就在最末端，新冠疫情爆发了，这对无家可归的人群产生了巨大的影响。那么，你知道现在关于新冠疫情和无家可归问题的情况如何吗，自从你报道这些故事以来，这一切是如何演变的？
all shaping up since you reported the stories. Yeah, I know a little bit. And I think the really short answer is that in the short term things have gotten a bit better in some ways. And I think in the long term, people are worried that things may get much worse. The reason they've gotten better is that there's just been a bunch of new money that has come in from the federal government to the states to address all kinds of things. And I think states have had a fair amount of leeway and sort of how they've used some of that money.
是的，我略知一二。我认为非常简短的回答是，在短期内，事情在某些方面已经变得好了一些。我认为从长期来看，人们担心情况可能会变得更糟。变好的原因在于，联邦政府向各州注入了一笔新的资金，用于解决各种问题。我认为各州在如何使用其中一部分资金方面拥有相当大的自主权。
But a lot of people, and we talked about it on our show, it probably heard about Project Room Key, which like was this massive project to move almost folks into hotel rooms during the pandemic, to get them out of like congregate shelter settings, which people were worried for good reason that there, you know, that COVID
但是很多人，我们在节目中也讨论过，可能听说过“客房钥匙计划”（Project Room Key），这是一个庞大的项目，旨在在大流行期间将几乎所有无家可归的人安置到酒店房间里，让他们离开人群密集的收容所环境，人们有充分的理由担心，你知道，新冠病毒
was gonna spread really easily in those spaces. So there was, yeah, this massive effort to move people into hotel rooms. There's definitely been criticisms of that program, but it moved thousands of people really fast into hotel rooms, not everybody but any stretch, but a lot of people, it was sort of like, oh wow, when there's a will and money, there is a way to quickly move people off of the streets. And now some of those programs are kind of winding down, I think, actually finding more permanent solutions
在这些空间里会极易传播。所以，是的，这是一项将人们转移到酒店房间里的庞大努力。该计划肯定受到过批评，但它确实以极快的速度将数千人转移到了酒店房间里，虽然远非所有人，但确实有很多人，这给人的感觉就像是，哦，天哪，只要有决心和资金，就一定能迅速让人们离开街头。现在其中一些项目正在逐步结束，我认为，实际上，为人们寻找更永久的解决方案在某些方面已经成为一个更大的挑战，让人们在酒店之后再做出另一次过渡。据我所知，遇到了各种各样的障碍，但事情正在发生，然后像奥克兰和旧金山这样的城市基本上都在试图购买他们曾经用来安置人们的一些酒店，并把它们变成人们的永久住房，本质上就是这样。所以这种情况正在发生。
for people has been like a much bigger challenge in some ways and getting people to sort of make another transition after the hotel. There's been all kinds of obstacles from what I understand, but it is happening and then like cities both Oakland and San Francisco are basically trying to buy some of these hotels that they had used to house people and just make them permanent housing for people, essentially. So that's happening.
然后还有一些资金可用于较小规模的干预措施。就像人们所说的“浅层补贴”的概念：想象一下，你的房租是2000美元，而你基本上每个月都能稳定地凑出1700美元。对于那些每个月只需要额外300美元的人来说，以前从来没有真正有过相关的干预措施。所以现在他们正在研究诸如此类的事情。我觉得有很多实验正在进行，因为有这么多的资金，他们就在想：
And then there's like money available for kind of smaller interventions. Like there's this idea of like what people call a shallow subsidy. So like imagine you, your rent is $2,000 and you pretty consistently can come up with like $1,700. There's never really been an intervention for people who just need that like $300 extra dollars every month. And so now like they're looking at stuff like that. I feel like there's a lot of like experimentation going on where there's just like all this money and they're like,
让我们试着做这个。让我们试着直接给人们发现金。让我们试着这样做。所以我认为这真的很好，希望一些更长期的项目能够从所有这些新资金产生的一些更具实验性的东西中脱颖而出。我认为困难的事情在于，我们所有人可能都眼睁睁地看着住房市场在大流行期间变得彻彻底底的疯狂，而且知道，如果你认为2019年在奥克兰买房很难，那就，哇，现在，它真的难太多了。而且，你知道，这现在已经开始转化为租赁市场
let's try doing this. Let's try just like giving people cash. Let's try this. And so I think that's really great. And hopefully, like, some longer term programs will come out of some of this more like experimental stuff that's happening from all this new money. I think that the the hard thing is that like we all have probably watched as like the housing market has gone just absolutely bananas during the pandemic and like know, like if you thought it was hard to buy a house in Oakland in 2019, it's like, whoa, it's, it's like so much harder now. And that, you know, it has now started to, to sort of translate into the rental market
也变得紧俏得多。这很糟糕。因为租房市场对许多人来说完全不切实际且负担不起，我们才陷入了疫情前那种无家可归的困境，而我们现在基本上正在走向一个更糟糕的困境。所以这真的很糟糕。这真的很糟糕。
becoming like much tighter also. And that's bad. Like, we were in the situation, we were in pre-COVID with homelessness because of a rental market that was just like completely unrealistic and unaffordable for so many people. And we're basically heading into a worse one. So that's really bad. That's really bad.
我不知道你是否还记得，就在疫情刚爆发的极短一段时间内，房租下降了，特别是在城市地区。而那已经结束了。由哈佛大学发布的一份图表，他们每年都会做这份关于住房的大型报告，这真正展示了现在正在发生的事情。
I don't know if you remember, but there was just this really brief moment in the beginning of the pandemic where rents went down, especially in more urban areas. And that is over. And this graph that was put out by Harvard, they do this big kind of report on housing every year, really sort of shows like what's happening now.
我刚刚把它发给你了。但是，哇。好的，所以你发来的图表就像是，底部有一些正常的噪音。然后到了2021年，它就像曲棍球棒式的增长一样飙升。太疯狂了。是的，就是直线上升。
I just texted it to you. But wow. OK, so the graph you sent is like a, it has the normal sort of noise at the bottom. And then it hits 2021 and it shoots up like a hockey stick type growth. It's crazy. Yeah, it's just straight up.
是的，这真的很糟糕。我不知道。过去几年里没有发生的一件事是，他们每年都会做一个大型活动，被称为“时间点统计”（point in time），本质上他们会派出志愿者团队去数他们在街上、车里遇到的无家可归的人数。这就像是一次大清点，在单独的一个早晨进行。他们在2020年没有做。我想他们在2021年也没有做，而它现在即将在2022年进行。所以我们真的不知道现在的数字在哪里，而且我认为
Yeah, that's really bad. I don't know. One thing that hasn't happened in a couple of years is like every year they do this big, it's called the point in time,, where they essentially send out teams of volunteers to count the number of homeless people that they encounter on the street in cars. It's like this big count and it happens on one single morning. They didn't do it in 2020. I don't think they did it in 2021 and it's about to happen now in 2022. So we don't really know where the numbers are right now and I think
每个人都非常渴望看到到底发生了什么，但可能还要再过一两年，我们才能真正看到疫情以及飙升的住房价格和租金价格，对这个本已十分严重的危机究竟造成了什么样的影响。很高兴能就此与你联系。我很高兴我们重新播出了这两集，我希望人们能听听其余的节目，并再次祝贺整个系列取得的成就。我太喜欢它了。这绝对是一个分水岭时刻。祝贺整个系列取得的成就。我太喜欢它了。这绝对是一个分水岭时刻。
Everybody's really anxious to see kind of what what's happening and it but it could still be another year or two before we really see like What kind of effect the pandemic and the skyrocketing, housing prices and rent prices have really done to a crisis that was already really bad. It's good to touch base with you about this. I'm glad that we're reprocasting the two episodes and I hope people listen to the rest of them and congratulations again on the achievement of the whole series. I just loved it. It was a real watershed moment for the rest of them. Congratulations again on the achievement of the whole series. I just loved it. It was a real watershed moment for 9% of his will.
我只是很高兴它存在于这个世界上。是的，我也是。非常感谢。而且这真的是，我不知道，我想象着能在那个故事上花时间是多么大的一种特权。这对我意义重大。所以我希望任何还没听过的人在那个故事上花时间是多么大的一种特权。这对我意义重大。所以我希望任何还没听过的人去听听看。
And I'm just happy it exists in the world. Yeah, me too. Thank you so much. And it was just, I don't know, I think about what a privilege it was to get that time on that story. And it just means so much to me. So I hope anyone who hasn't heard it yet on that story and it just like means so much to me. So I hope anyone who hasn't heard it yet will check it out.
是的，真的很好。是的。真的很好。是的。是的。是的。《按需分配》由凯蒂·明格与洛什玛·多恩（Loshma Dawn）共同制作，执行主编惠特尼·亨利·莱斯特（Whitney Henry Lester），
Yeah, it's really good. Yeah. It's really good. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. According to Need was produced by Katie Minkle with Loshma Dawn and managing editor Whitney Henry Lester,
执行制作人罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars），剪辑丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollock）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）和乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg），索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）和克里斯·巴鲁比（Chris Barubey）提供额外支持，音乐由斯旺·里亚尔（Swan Rial）创作。库尔特·科尔斯特（Kurt Colestet）担任数字总监，这两集的原创声音工程由凯文·拉姆齐（Kevin Ramsey）完成，事实核查由艾米·盖恩斯（Amy Gaines）完成，品牌和设计由“大得多”（much more）完成。特别感谢凯蒂为这个系列采访的每个人，以及玛丽索尔·梅迪纳·卡德纳（Marisol Medina Cadena）、艾莉森·德扬（Alison D'Young）和切尔西·米勒（Chelsea Miller）。这次重新广播的混音和技术制作由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martín Gonzales）完成。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。在美丽的
executive produced by me Roman Mars, editing by Lisa Pollock, Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney Hall, Christopher Johnson, and Joe Rosenberg, additional support from Sophia Klatsker, Vivian Leigh, and Chris Barubey, music by Swan Rial. Kurt Colestet is the digital director, original sound engineering on these two episodes by Kevin Ramsey, fact checking by Amy Gaines, branding and design, by much more. Special thanks to everyone Katie interviewed for this series as well as Marisol Medina Cadena, Alison D'Young, and Chelsea Miller. Mix and Tech Production on this re-broadcast by Martín Gonzales. We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful.
奥克兰市中心，加利福尼亚州。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与有关该程序的讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我（@Roman Mars）以及节目（@99PI at work）。我们在Instagram上，网址是@two。你可以在99PI dot org slash need收听《按需分配》的所有其他剧集。它也有自己的播客动态。你可以在99mpi.org-need收听《按需分配》的所有其他剧集。它也有自己的播客动态。
Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI at work. We're on Instagram and right at two. You can listen to all the other episodes of According to Need at 99PI dot org slash need. It also has its own podcast feed. You can listen to all the other episodes of According to Need at 99mpi.org-need. It also has its own podcast feed.
只需在你喜欢的播客应用中搜索“按需分配”（According to Need），就能找到它。顺便在那里留下评论，以鼓励其他人收听。如果你迷路了，请留在原地，在99mpi.org的结账处与我会合。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Just do a search in your favorite podcast app for According to Need and you will find it. And leave a review for a while you're there so other people will be encouraged to listen. And if you get lost, stay still and meet me near the checkout at 99mpi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
只需在您喜爱的播客应用中搜索 According to Need，您就能找到它。顺便留个评价，这样就能鼓励其他人来听。如果你迷路了，请站在原地，在 99mpi.org 的收银台附近等我。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。